ok ci siamo incredibile un altro capri
ma ora ti spiego che cos'è questa roba
questa roba consiste nel rispondere a
delle domande tipo il milionario non
sono esperto nel modo più oggi prova a
fare le domande su di te ok tu provo a
darmi qualche consiglio se vedi che
sbaglio troppo
dammi un confino se faccio qualcosa di
completamente sbagliato che è il sun
domande su di te io ho solo una domanda
di farò qualche figuraccia 1 io credo
diverse e tante e vivendo molto questa
teoria è che questa cosa è un casino
la prima domanda di oggi è al centro la
rai per le figure in ogni figura di
merda a 100mila in più dovremo
migliorare gli istanti anni a gabry
ponte 2017 ora questo è facile basta
andare su wiki d'orcia il tempo cioè 17
secondi cos'è e ai nomi ke adesso se ne
mettono troppo voi mi lasciate in merda
ma se io non sono il tetto lo giuro non
so quanti anni hai
[Musica]
nelle mele 30 43 anni veramente parte
rivolta o 39 se li porta bene dai 94 44
pronto quanto già fatti a 71 73
c'è il doppio dei miei anni va bene va
bene val d'enza re è stata fantastica
partenza giusta di chi è la canzone tu
sei gabry ponte pedanti e cioè di jokic
alfredo vasco rossi per ora almeno
questa fosse l'unica che poteva giocare
tra tutte a chi video musicale a partire
questa foto ovviamente lo sai è allora
il posto di cosentino
vai siamo figli siamo figli pitagorica
ed è quello che raccomandava di gela
facciamo e ho capito ma non c'erano
nomine nell'aria non cela tra questa ma
io penso fosse visto il tono non lo sa
neanche lui che video è marega da ma dai
che l'abbiate caso però scusi mi ami
caro 4 l'ha già capito i toni non
ragazzi di treviglio io non so neanche
ball seccata e non la sapeva neanche lui
va bene sono scusato per tutto il video
gli aprì ponte paragonabile a una figura
mitologica profeta uomo comune di visco
abbiamo parlato anche sicuro perché
ovviamente come si chiama l'ex ss
ha un nome a un nome lui deve essere più
dei video mi chiamo i tuoi fan mi
linciano l'idea anno aspetta sordo so
per quale motivo ricordando va bene ma
non mi linciate ancora oggi queste
canzoni che per quanto è stata
realizzata anche da gigi doug la soc
un amore per cecità che non sempre ti
viene la risposta quando non sai
qualcosa e tu vivi nell'area sempre
risposta è nell'aria
vabbè next one sia per portare fissato
due sue canzoni unendo le quali nella
regione
la blue gene sod1 escluderei vivi
nell'aria profilare conoscere spagnola
nome ma veramente non so ma quando hai
fatto questa cosa
kakà perchè grain merda partendo magari
con io sono stati oggetto di kolontar è
questa gli adorati prima perché negli
anni a capri ponte 40 andrea grazie
grazie perché le soglie di conte niente
proprio niente neanche le guardo le
altre subito oltre a gabry ponte chi
sono gli altri componenti del 7
riflessiva non ne ho la più pallida idea
uno non ha i capelli aspetto si svolge
questa è l'altra problema a paid to
write
tra gli altri di sicuro che verranno
aveva mettere 100 kg nell'aria nel
centro vive nell'area si guarda la
sapevo lo sapevo perché sono sfilato io
sostengo del politico la cassa spinge
come spinge
ma quanto segue centrico però dai quale
la seconda canzone mi chiamo di punti
con la prima la seconda certo mimì
nell'aria grossa cambiamento netto di
nell'aria alla fine saldi 2000 e la
prima e quindi lei non ha suggerito a
sapere con chi ha collaborato dire il
ponte perfezione la fine del mondo tanti
no come a roberto piva beta io è il
magistero sta parzialmente corrette
direi che siamo passati appunto è un
passato però io vorrei se vorreste per
una cosa ti do potevo rispondere anche
alle domande su progetti in teoria no
però mi faccio fare lo stesso non dormo
ormai da un secolo e parte di que
canzoni capri comite non darmi ormai non
secolo per qualche giro gli occhiali
viola sotto suggerimento non è mia e un
remix remix e non è comuni nell'aria
julia la risposta era era giulia e lo
sapevamo la grafica sul letto da noi
siamo noi la solenne e la risposta
sembra davanti al 30 è sempre chiudere
poi l'aria e giulia il gruppo papa fa
parte capri con the mob dei backstreet
dall il ceo doug lombardi backstreet
boys hanno marcato da un elemento
prioritario il brano che ne sanno i 2000
si tunisi un cuore di gelo ha prodotto
mandanti non è sufficiente
non appena non è un dj qui in contanti e
poliedrica che voleva fare un sacco di
cose anche voi youtuber ogni tanto per
fare con chi dei mesi capri ha fatto una
whisper cia hai fatto un video con un
altro youtuber a io quindi non sono il
primo quindi questo video può
concludersi guai tradito nel nell'intimo
era peggiore
portable extra un piano che avrei ponte
comincia a collaborare con n2o questo
non lo sono anch'io pensate come posso
sapere io sulle app 2008 2001 2006
integrando per esclusione dopo
l'esclusione dal 2008 secondo me 2003
via 6 ha risposto lui è il capo non è
possibile però io ti vedo che sotto le
insegne rockin che arriverà il giorno in
cui tu riuscirai a meno di me
madonna insieme ma battista matura
dentro spiriti spiriti tipi di spiriti
potenti di vivo gli anni nell'aria vivi
nell'aria rievochiamo sinai chiuderà
sapeva invece le ultime due ragazze poi
concludiamo speriamo che vada bene
questo mi stimava il primo album degli
eiffel europa avrà quindi degli che
conosci tutti conosci i titoli delle
canzoni conosce tipo degli alberghi le
persone non i nomi delle personalità mi
piaceva piangere in questione con due
premi o vi è una figura di merda finale
gabry ponte ha fatto nel 2012 il remix
di una canzone con dolce hamel e qual è
questa canzone
qual è la vostra quindi non meritano
rispetto giusta sexy dj mad men l'oblio
and my hand siccome queste sono simili
dell'uri sia una di queste prime cinque
[Musica]
la dai due bei ragazzi io direi che
ringrazio capri per aver partecipato a
questo video ho fatto veramente nelle
figure meschine però se è andato bene
o meglio che all'esame di maturità
sicuramente ringrazio anche giulia per
aver dato la risposta sbagliata di tra
quelle che c'erano
grazie ancora gabry ponte vi lascio con
l'altro che ha fatto lui quindi tutto
capri volte questo video e lo studio le
mie domande su provvigioni vuoi farla è
sicuro va bene e non ci vediamo al
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]